[Music]
as much as i enjoy focusing on the
positive aspects of the zelda series
every so often it can also be fun to do
some nitpicking you know to be that guy
who points out little mistakes that are
ultimately of very little consequence
and are only noticed by the hardest of
hardcore lore freaks out there and what
better victim to choose than hyrule
warriors age of calamity because even if
i'm wrong about things or you don't
agree at the end of the day it's just a
spin-off title is the game canon is it
not canon who the hell knows at this
point i'm still not sure about it but
whether it is or isn't canon i think
it's safe to say that it probably has
little to no consequence for the future
of the series yes the story has been
written and supervised by members of the
original zelda team and it features some
of the same voice cast but the story
itself takes place in an alternate
timeline which seems to have little to
no bearings on the events of breath of
the wild at the very most we might see
counterpart characters from age of
calamity make an appearance in breath of
the wild too like maybe aster will show
up along the way as we don't know what
his fate was in breath the wild's
timeline either way since we're getting
a new story dlc for the game in november
today i want to focus on some aspects
which didn't make sense to me or are
flat-out mistakes or oversights on the
part of the story writers for age of
calamity now some of these are more
subjective than others and some are
about as nitpicky as it gets so please
don't get on me for it it's just for
good fun and if you have your own
explanations for some of these don't
share them
yeah don't share them in the comments
below don't hesitate to share your ideas
in the comments below with that said
here are the biggest lore mistakes in
hyrule warriors age of calamity
around zora's domain in breath of the
wild we can find a number of stone
monuments which shed some light on the
history of the zora one of these
monuments tells the story about how king
dorafan did battle with a stray guardian
which had somehow managed to get close
to zora's domain this story is also
mentioned in breath the wild's
complementary book creating a champion
notice how it says that this happened
after the great calamity which makes
sense seeing as before the calamity
there were no corrupted guardians they
were either still buried or under the
control of the shika and during the
calamity zoro's domain was never reached
by the guardians it's only after the
calamity was already over that a stray
guardian left over from the war wandered
into the zora highlands according to the
monument the encounter with the guardian
is the reason why dorafan has a scar on
his forehead a token of his triumph and
yet in age of calamity the king of the
zora already has the scar when first
meeting him in chapter 2 which is long
before the calamity even started now i'm
sure it's possible to explain this away
it is an alternate timeline so maybe he
got the scar from one of the monster
attacks on the domain it is a bit
coincidental that he would get an
identical looking scar from a monster
but oh well one could also make the
claim that due to the influence of aster
a corrupted guardian managed to get into
zoro's domain earlier but you would
think he'd at least mention it like hey
um what's up with those guardians you
guys are building one of them just came
into the domain and tried to freaking
kill me aren't they supposed to you know
protect us but no he never says anything
about it so the more likely scenario is
that they simply reuse dorafan's
character model from breath to wild and
forgot to remove the scar from his
texture a simple and understandable
oversight but an oversight nonetheless
i've had a gripe with this one ever
since i first saw it while playing the
demo of the game inside the royal
ancient tech lab pura and robbie have
been studying tarako the little mini
guardian who traveled from brethwell's
timeline to the timeline of age of
calamity according to pura she's been
able to extract visual data from the
guardian's memory photographs of hyrule
castle and town in ruin this is the
moment they first discover what will
happen in the future giving them the
advantage and opportunity to change the
outcome the issue is not the fact that
terraco has pictures of this happening
he is a robot so i can believe that he
keeps recordings of his visual
observations my problem is how the heck
did he manage to get all these different
camera angles because remember tereko
has laid dormant for at least 10 years
stored inside a box in zelda's room as
soon as he wakes up he only lingers in
this timeline for about a minute or so
he crawls out of the box looks out the
window and sees that everyone is screwed
opens up a time portal almost
immediately with a guardian stalker on
his heels and is flung inside the portal
while being pursued by malice so how the
hell did he get all these different
camera angles of the destruction you
would expect that he only has visual
data from his vantage point out the
window from zelda's laboratory the first
picture makes sense it seems like a shot
of castletown from a bird's-eye
perspective but then there's shots on
the ground from inside castle town with
the castle in the background and another
one from what seems like as far as the
town walls again while facing the castle
and according to robbie there should be
even more pictures but some of it was
fragmented there's no way teriko had
enough time to take pictures from these
vantage points so what did he hack into
the other guardians like he extracted
the visual data from a stalker or a sky
watcher if so why does he never use this
ability in the rest of the story you'd
think it would be incredibly helpful to
see from the vantage point of ganon's
army you can predict their advances
their next targets if someone's in
trouble heck he could have seen that
king rome made it out alive and spared
zelda the misery but nope he's just
magically able to take pictures from
impossible angles without any
explanation it's about as convenient as
a plot device can get
this is a mistake that many people
noticed pretty quickly when they first
got a chance to play the game's demo
it's the second mission in the game so
it takes place early on the narrator
says that zelda link and impa made their
way to a research facility in hatteno
this is an obvious mistake in the script
the facility they are visiting is the
royal ancient tech lab which is not in
ateno but rather close to the breach of
demise on the other side of the map they
somehow mixed up this facility with
perez tech lab which is found close to
ateno this lab also wouldn't be built
until long after the calamity the voice
actor for king rome probably already
recorded the line and they simply
decided to just leave it as it is
instead of going back and having to
re-record again i'm not entirely sure if
this mistake is also present in the
japanese version or any of the other
languages for that matter if it is or
isn't i'm curious to hear about it from
you guys
out of all mistakes mentioned here today
this one is by far the most subjective
one i think it's a mistake that they use
the tapestry to illustrate the game's
story at the beginning as cool as it
looks it was meant to depict a battle
from 10 000 years ago when the guardians
and the divine beasts were first built
and the ancient heroes and the sheikah
monks of old succeeded in beating
calamity ganon no guardians were taken
over by ganon as far as we know it was a
clean win against the demon king it was
only because of this battle that ganon
came back with a new plan later and
corrupted the mechanical army i mean
sure i get it the tapestry is iconic and
from an animation standpoint it looks
cool to see the picture of ganon
starting to move and soar across the
screen but from a lore perspective it
only makes things unnecessarily
confusing the two characters we see here
are not the link in zelda from breath of
the wild it's a different unknown hero
and what we can assume is an earlier
incarnation of zelda tereco appearing
behind her doesn't make sense story-wise
it's as simple as that there is no
tapestry of the great calamity from 100
years ago in fact the tapestry we see
here is still a bit of a mystery the
only thing they change to it is adding
an additional champion on top of the
four divine beasts which also kinda
spoils the fact that riju teba yunobo
and saidon will appear in the game
imagine if we had no clue at all that
this would happen it would probably have
made a much bigger impact again from a
design perspective i get why they used
it it looks pretty it's something people
would recognize from breath of the wild
but it makes no sense at all when it
comes to the pre-established lore
this one is a classic example of
sacrificing story consistency for
gameplay one of the missions in chapter
four titled when courage fails sees
zelda visiting the spring of courage
inside the farron province right smack
in the middle of the zonai ruins when
they are suddenly ambushed by hordes of
monsters trying to take out the princess
once and for all as the heroes try to
defend themselves and make their way out
of the forest one objective involves
turning on these ancient water spouts to
clear debris blocking the road we can
find a broken one lying around early on
and zelda comments on it okay cool it
works for the mission itself i mean
shoot half the objectives in the game
involves activating some thingamajigs
across the map to advance further so
yeah but again from a story perspective
it clashes with breath of the wild
because where are these ancient water
spouts in that game we don't find them
anywhere adding things to the world as a
way to create objectives is fine but it
can sometimes mess with the overall lore
could they be destroyed in breath of the
wild's timeline i mean sure but i don't
really see why that would be the case
they seem to be made from the same type
of material as the guardians and they
can still be seen laying around
everywhere so logically speaking some of
these ancient super soakers or at least
parts of them should still be laying
around in breath of the wild as well
right
finally i have some quick honorable
mentions things which didn't make it on
the list because they were either too
small of an issue or because maybe they
do have a clear explanation that doesn't
require reaching too far first is the
map which has a few small
inconsistencies on it like the ruins of
certain locations which should still be
standing most notable the merida
exchange or deja village which is
somehow already submerged also for some
reason they completely removed the
temple of time in eastern abbey instead
of making new versions of them on the
map which are still intact next is
taiflo runes which are shown without the
black mist around it i didn't include
this one because as far as i'm aware
it's never explained when this black
mist started forming around these ruins
for all we know it didn't happen until
after the calamity when it was time to
set up the trials for the hero so it
could have an easy explanation another
one that i wanted to include but
ultimately thought
whatever is hastu because i get it hestu
is a character that a lot of people like
so obviously they wanted to include him
as a fighter but when you really think
about it it doesn't make a whole lot of
sense the koroks are supposed to be
invisible to almost everyone and all of
a sudden everyone can see him including
rivali the prick pure of heart my ass
paragus what about the monsters how are
they able to see hestu if he's supposed
to be visible only to those pure of
heart from their vantage point are they
being beaten up by an invisible force
that would be pretty funny but anyway i
decided to exclude this one because it's
so obviously done to pad out the
character roster without any care for
the story i mean we get to fight as
calamity ganon against calamity ganon
yeah totally canon stuff right there the
last one is more of a general mistake
that is too big to explain in one video
and that is simply the overall story
direction this isn't really a lore
mistake but more so my own personal
feelings of disappointment about the
story the time travel shenanigans that
make it all way more confusing and
inconsistent than it needed to be the
many way too convenient plot devices the
fact that the game was marketed as the
prequel to breath of the wild while in
reality having very little to do with
the actual events from 10 000 years ago
etc because of all this i just find it
harder and harder to care about this
story it doesn't reveal anything new
about the lore of breath the wild it
doesn't have any impact on breath to
wall 2 heck as i said we still don't
even know if this game is supposed to be
canon or not but even if it is it's so
disconnected that it doesn't really
matter at the end of the day and judging
from the general reaction to the new
story dlc of the game it seems like i'm
not the only one who feels that way it
was a fun game with some amazing
cutscenes and cool new characters but
that's about it for me now i'm not
ruling out that the new story dlc might
explain some new stuff we do see a new
depiction of the moment terrico awakens
which is supposed to take place in
breath the wild's timeline maybe it even
explains the inconsistency i mentioned
earlier about the weird camera angles
who knows from what i can gather the
story seems to be sort of a prequel to
some of age of calamity's events perhaps
it shows how aster first came into
contact with calamity ganon from the
future something which i pointed out in
my review of the game was sorely lacking
from the game's narrative i think this
new story might have something to do
with that which robbie mentions inside
the royal tech lab namely that there is
even more information inside terraco but
it's been fragmented the dlc is called
guardian of remembrance and it shows
glass fragments with imagery on it maybe
we'll see what happened after terraco
jumped inside the portal and before he
ended up at the shika tower in central
hyrule which is kind of an unexplained
gap the guardian stalker we see
awakening here is likely the very same
one that found its way up to the tower
and into zelda's laboratory to try and
stop terrico and ultimately released its
malice into the portal so yeah if i had
to guess it probably shows what tereko
and calamity ganon were up to before
link finds terraco during the battle for
hyrule field anyway that wraps it up for
today a big thanks to all of you for
watching to my mods my patreons channel
members and to sony valisente korok
dance banoon and twilight wolfo thank
you all so much for the support i will
see you all in the next video this is
dawn signing off and
have a good one
[Music]
you